I'm gonna sort of just roll right into a
number of lightning round thoughts that
have occurred to me in the last few
months while I've been up here talking
to a number of people in different
faculties and hopefully speaking to a
number of the questions that the
panelists have all raised today
specifically like Pilar Sara I mean mark
as it kind of goes on because so if one
thing an artist can offer instead of a
technologist is I don't have any
solutions
I've just got questions so I'm gonna
sort of run through some questions that
have really come to mind up here so we
we collaborate on this project one of
the things that there it is at the Met
everyone looking very fancy and this
very fancy space and for at Marc
Hamilton for Microsoft generated this
this was projected on the floor and it's
sort of iterating version so once you
move away from 3d comparisons into 2d
comparisons you start to create very
interesting and complicated turbulent
spaces and objects that Rick can't
really exist so the question for me
looking at this was like what does this
interpolation mean how does how do we
sort of begin to think about this as a
meaningful space because the danger is
that you know as an artist I love this
kind of stuff I'm like this is cool this
is the new look and indeed there was a
show at the same time in the serpentine
gallery by Pierre week famous artists
using exactly again generated images
that's all it was on big monitors and
the press went apeshit for it was the
new stuff but is this just machine wash
data this is the question an artist has
to ask it's a hard question because all
through the history of art we've loved
machine wash data the newest look is not
always something that has an
informational basis this is a question
that Caroline Jones raised a few years
to me and I think still it's a very
interesting question we think about this
is if representation is epistemological
in other words things have to mean
something how do we make this without
just being seduced by these kind of
supercool surfaces how do we know they
mean something this is an example that
Peter Galison put forward in one of her
powerpoints of a scientist making you
know the kinds of cool things that an
artist like me goes wow that is so cool
I guess I'll make a painting like that
what are we doing with these kinds of
collaborations but what is interesting
in this question is this this blurring
of boundaries between knowledge states
this idea of turbulence also
seems to be a big problem at every scale
so I think this has a little laser I'm
gonna so we're going from here from the
quantum scale to the nano scale all the
way up to dark energy and dark matter
turbulence is a system that seems to be
on everyone's minds it's an unsolved
problem which is of course to an artist
means there's a little bit of space
where an artist might be able to step in
and ask an interesting question which is
why I came to the the title of my talk I
work in porous media and I found this
book in the South Station lying on on a
on a bench and I thought this is a sign
that and then I thought I'll just do the
sequel turbulent Strikes Back so a
question that I'm gonna put in various
different ways in the next part of this
lightning round and then hopefully to
the rest of the panel and to the
audience is what is a shared theory of
picture how can we generate a mutual
visual space between art and science and
not fall into this trap of just machine
washing one beautiful image back into
something that we can look at but not
understand or make something that is
beautiful to look at what can never be
reinterpreted these are some of the
criteria you need to generate a picture
state that is sort of mutually operable
this is sort of an artist pretending to
be a scientist so science has these
beautiful examples like the standard
model or the amplitude hydron where
complex informational states are in fact
concentrated into a kind of picture and
this is sort of my version of it you
know I try my eye my best but it's and
so for me this is a kind of coherent
theory of picture so how can we sort of
bring these two things together
especially you know I have a kind of
urgency in this because I've got one
year here to get the greatest minds in
the world to help me figure this out so
one answer is it has to start including
all the different kinds of time that are
needed to analyze different types of
data and those timescales are as wildly
divergent as the physical scales of
gravity weak force strong forests and so
forth we got another question that I
sort of came up with so if we if we
begin to stack these series of time each
one corresponding to a particular moment
in human history we can start thinking
about that late in space that Sarah was
talking about as a chronology of picture
States out of which we can be
introduced a feature language and I'm
happy to go into much more detail about
this it's a sort of weird side job of
mine is just making diagrams of all
human history at the end of them.this so
this was a sequence of diagrams that
goes from divinatory States early
civilizations the kind that would make
you errs and pots to contemporary
society where you've got superposition
as a sort of local state in physics so
this was an example of an exhibition
where I tried this at your picture
stacking pictures stacked upon pictures
stacked upon pictures imagine if you had
all of your graphs but you sort of put
them all on top of each other so
obviously and there's a VR performance
as part of it we can go inside the
picture States and imagine them all
instead of a giant information room but
this happens right so as soon as you do
that
all the pictures States start to pile up
on top of each other and all the
participating entities start to affect
each other and it becomes unintelligible
so this is like my first experiment this
was last fall so I came here with this
very fresh on my mind so the question
I'd like to pose to the audience of
geniuses is you know is there an answer
at a different by thinking about this at
a different scale is the can we modelled
scaling across informational structures
so this is the problem you know any kind
of informational surface has to maintain
these four theories of time scientists
simultaneously to be legible so which
creates this kind of radiant picture
space which is starts to become
provocatively like a kind of surface the
kinds of surface that you might see in a
laboratory at MIT so I'm wondering if
something like this can be manufactured
here with your help it's really this is
a kind of blatant thing for help
is it possible to sort of use new
visualization technologies like electron
microscopes or dark energy surveys to
immerse us within these force relations
and model it in a kind of interstitial
way can we simulate stacked scaling
informational and picture regimes
incorporating turbulence and ontological
and temporal minima I'm reading that off
the monitor down here
because it's a it's like a mouthful of a
sentence but it's definitely the ask so
you know in this case I've shown only
five of the picture states stacked
against each other but what I imagine is
that at a certain point they start to
become legible to each other in time in
a way that they could never be in space
and this would allow the sort of
potential for a question like this to
evolve where you have a sort of
correlative space where informational
regimes can correlate up to the next
scale and this kind of relational theory
would allow a user for example to enter
VR and wander from the very smallest
subatomic space into the nano scale into
the correlative space of human cognition
into this sort of intricacies of the
visual system reclaiming sort of the
byproducts of the correlative space that
sort of Marcus talked about how we make
things that we see and then go keep
going on up to the scale of you know
baryonic matter dark matter and finally
to the scale of dark energy and this
sort of so what I'm imagining is that
the thing that has to be solved here is
not can I put pictures of all these
things in a row of course I can but can
I represent the turbulent
interrelationships the phase transitions
between the states in a way that is
meaningful this seems to me to be like a
very interesting and potentially cool
collaboration anyone anyone out there
you know raise your hands I got someone
in the back row just raising the head
right there so that's good one then
you'd probably you know we've got the
Magnificent Seven
[Music]
so that's what I'm looking for and
that's what I think is possible this is
going back to the questions that Sarah
raised of like also what if we could
interpolate all human data sets not just
pasta pots or pictures to pictures or
sounds - sounds but sounds - pictures
pots - dark energy
oceans - atoms that is the promise I
think of AI is that it begins to present
an opportunity for artists and
scientists to share a set of
informational inquiries the results are
going to be wildly different there is no
doubt in my mind at the end of this
someone will look at what I've done and
go well that is certainly not science
and I
I would hope not just as you wouldn't
you really wouldn't want me to be a
scientist right and I also think that
this is not necessary for artists to
imagine that there's a kind of
distinction where someone would ever say
well that is not our because the future
is where all these things are just
completely shared and we can sort of
step into that new frontier just sort of
bringing it all back home now this is
like the slow dance of the of the event
thinking about how amazing it would be
that's an enlargement of one of those
fabulous glitches in the nano scale
which to me reminds me just inextricably
about the early days of the Old West but
also the early days of movie studios
when you would make an idea of the West
using that visualization technology you
had so there's a kind of beautiful
moment of this like beginning together
of a news of system of vision of
envisioning that I think where we're at
the dawn of so this idea of a frontier
this really makes me feel about
frontiers a lot when I look at these
pictures it's something that we can all
I think kind of embrace artists and
scientists together
thank you
[Applause]
you